so Indiana what was a TC for like snack
uber and like Google yeah so did it
depends on how you calculate it but
basically around through and UK for snap
and uber and then for Google about like
240 K damn raisin before we continue
this video I just want to say thank you
so much for blinkers for sponsoring this
video
nowadays people are so busy we have
full-time jobs hobbies friends or like
me you have a YouTube channel to run so
you can't just find the time to sit down
and learn there is tons of knowledge you
can learn from reading books but with
the busy schedule that's hard if you
wish you can get the main insights from
the books and apply right away to your
life then I really recommend the app
called Linkous blanka's is the only app
that takes their best insights they need
to know information from thousands of
non-fiction books and condenses them
down into just 15 minutes so you can
read it or listen to it a lot of
nonfiction books tend to repeat itself
or give a lot of examples so that's why
I like plinkus because it gets straight
to the point and it tells you in 15
minutes I use blink is right before bed
for 15 minutes allowing me to absorb all
that knowledge before sleeping I've read
these books and I highly recommend you
check out the 7 Habits of Highly
Effective People because everyone talks
about it and also home odors which is
cool because it talks about a prediction
of humanity with technology now the
first a hundred people to go on blink is
calm slash DOMA will get a whole week
for free so you can try it it out and
also you get 25% off if you decide to go
for the full membership now these spots
are going to grow fast but for people
who get in there I highly recommend
reading those two books I mentioned
which is 7 Habits of Highly Effective
People and homogeneous now remember the
first 7 days are completely free so you
can cancel at any time no problem
alright thanks for coming Cyrus do you
want to say your name first sure I
waited at you alright
[Laughter]
okay okay all right you know thank you
for coming Cyrus and yeah so let's just
have like a casual conversation cuz you
know I'm not try hard anymore so we can
just say yes your name what do you do
and then just so that you could get some
context sure I'm Cyrus she I just
recently joined it uber I'm sorry
did you yeah so I met I met Jonah at
Facebook we are in the same team in in
July 2017 and then I was there for about
a year and a half and then went through
interview prep cycle so yeah nice nice
so wait so what college did you go - I
went to a small liberal arts college in
Kentucky at about 1,400 students code
Center College in 1,400 students yes
forty hundred students total weight the
total total yeah like five four years
four years wow that's crazy huh and what
is liberal arts college if you don't
know so basically they try to emphasize
like a general education so trying to
like these well-rounded students so when
I was there I wrote a lot of like papers
I was really a philosophy major no I'm
so I switch to a computer science junior
year so it's bit late i CFC okay so the
reason why I brought you here is because
you have a very famous post on CSR your
questions right on reddit so yeah so I'm
gonna put that in the description but
can you kind of tell me like what that
post is about yeah yeah so basically I
spent a lot of time reading the
subreddit before I joined Facebook I
mean I saw a lot of posts talking about
people joining you know at Facebook
Google big tech companies and a lot of
them had you know I pretty impressive
backgrounds from like Stanford
you know you waterloo Stanford of Canada
but you know I came from a smaller parts
college I didn't really know anybody I
got it
companies and so when I did eventually
make it out there I thought I could you
know give back and talk about how I you
know they do okay so you did have a CS
degree but it's from like a [ __ ] college
right pretty much yeah but then and then
when you came out you got what you got a
job but like yeah yes I graduated in the
beginning of 2015 and I joined like a
big financial company I'm still in the
south and then then I joined a start-up
and then throughout this time I had been
getting like interview calls for like
Amazon Microsoft Google but um I just
didn't really focus on studying and
didn't really do well and then finally I
got another call from Facebook and I
decided that you know this was um the
moment so you're gonna try hard mode yes
I went to try hard mode I went all-in
you know I studied like 120 hours in
like a month
a lot working full-time it's really
grinded and just wrote a post about that
experience that's perfect because I just
quit my job you know it but my audience
doesn't know I just could my job as a
data scientist and now I want to go back
into sweet you know so I've already
prepared and I've interviewed a lot but
I want to hear like your take even how
did you start like okay I don't know you
have your full-time jobs there right you
quit or no you just study on the side
yeah I think ideally you don't quit cuz
it you know it's really risky um but it
does depend I I have a friend who
successfully quit her job in studying
for time and she was actually you know
Austin North Carolina and made it out to
Silicon Valley but um so I think the
benefit of quitting is that it's kind of
like you get like a forcing function you
get that desperation but obviously it's
a big gamble if it doesn't work out and
kind of screwed yeah ideally you keep
your job and you study on the side so
yeah okay
so you study on this side yeah I study
on the side book times so you just went
back home and start studying ah yeah so
not yeah pretty much everyday I guess
but basically yeah I came up with like a
be playing in the schedule sort of a
timeline and then one thing is I just
recently another post but one thing I
talk about is that I think it really
helps to have like quantifiable like
goals
just because it's so easy to become
frustrated in the beginning and it's
hard to tell like you've been making
progress and so my goals were to study
you know like a hundred hours and do
like 100 coding problems a hundred
coding problems okay yeah and what did
you use for these coding problems yeah
so I mainly use leak code so leak codes
really trendy right now but I think it
came from him for it
yeah I did I think it's worth it just
the return on investment but yeah so I
did a lot of leak code I think is the
most efficient way of studying so before
Facebook you did leak code I did yeah I
did I did some for Facebook I did I
think I did about like 76 boxes yeah and
then this time around I did like 130
hard mediums are easy
mostly mediums I think mediums is the
best bang for your buck Easy's being you
can cycle the road often really fast but
you don't really like struggle that much
so you don't really get the experience
and their hearts or like you struggle
too much so you don't cover as much
ground okay but your job at Facebook was
as a data engineer yeah okay okay what
do you do now so now I'm a software
engineer so actually I guess similar to
you I wanted to transfer back to being a
software engineer but yeah I didn't
really find the transition too hard
I think interviewing they mostly want to
see if I give if you can code and if you
can show that through the coding
interview they don't really care okay so
so data engineer they still asked you
like to code stuff yeah like algorithm
since yeah okay so you did about semi
something questions and was that like an
overkill for Facebook or was it yeah so
for Facebook it was a little bit
overkill because that was a data
engineer
position but this time around for like
uber and Google it was about the right
amount I think so your goal was a
hundred hours like total I don't know
until you start the interview yeah so I
ended up doing about a hundred and
twenty but I think wait for before
Facebook no sorry
before Facebook it was I our members yes
are you okay before video here your face
okay once I guess like 102 and yeah or
120 or something like that but yeah I I
tracked my time just because I feel like
if you only track problems then you're
like your son advice to like only do
easy problems in a way like
subconsciously and if you only track
time it's kind of like you you're
incentivized to be inefficient I spent a
lot of time for a problem like it
doesn't really matter it's so that's why
I got kind of shaken right yeah I get
kind of metric